Diese katastrophe würde das ende der raumfahrt bedeuten eine kettenreaktion an deren ende die zerstörung der allermeisten
satelliten rund um die erde steht dass kessler syndrom
ausgelöst durch weltraumschrott und dieses syndrom das ist gar nicht so unwahrscheinlich wenn wir nicht bald anfangen den weltraumschrott weg zu räumen
jetzt hat ein europäischer satellit zum ersten mal ein manöver zum aufsammeln von weltraumschrott
absolviert klicks um science-fiction hier gibt es täglich neue science videos abonniert den channel gerne herzlich willkommen
Immer wieder schlittern wir daran vorbei ist gab bereits
200 kollisionen im orbit der erde und jede produziert wieder neue schrott teilchen inzwischen geht man von
166 millionen trümmerteilen aus die um die erde schwirren
7600 tonnen extrem gefährlicher müll wir sind im moment quasi zeuge eines kessler syndroms in zeitlupe
spektakulärer höhepunkt 2009 stoßen der us-satellit nummer
33 das iridium
satellitentelefon netzes
gewicht eine halbe tonne und der russische satellit cosmos 2251
zusammen bei einer aufprallgeschwindigkeit von rund 40000 kilometern pro stunde bleibt von beiden satelliten nichts mehr übrig außer rund
100.000 schrottteilen sie haben die möglichkeit für den nächsten unfall deutlich erhöht zum beispiel eine kollision mit der ss der
internationalen raumstation wie am 24 märz
2015 ein schrott teil dieser koalition steuert mit hoher geschwindigkeit
auf die iss zu es stammt vom russischen satelliten kosmos 2251
die nah sagt kann eine schwere beschädigung der station nicht ausschließen für die astronauten gibt es nur eine rettung 2 an die iss
angedockte russische sojus kapseln im fall der katastrophe könnten sie sofort abdocken und zur erde zurückfliegen
die nasa rechnet also ganz konkret mit einer schlimmen katastrophe bis hin zur vernichtung der ss also sie kann sie nicht ausschließen und
bereitet sich deshalb darauf vor laut esa chef johann dietrich wörner ist weltraumschrott eine globale herausforderung
jetzt endlich muss man sagen wird an einer lösung gearbeitet die britische universität hat
erstmals einen satelliten ausgesetzt um das aufsammeln von weltraumschrott zu testen der name des experiments remove debris also auf deutsch
entfernen trümmer und das scheint gelungen zu sein
dafür im erd orbit ausgesetzter klein satellit wurde mit hilfe eines netzes eingefangen und zum absturz gebracht
dafür wurde das netz in fünf metern entfernung
ausgeworfen und der satellit eingefangen zitat um diese
netztechnologie zum einfachen vom weltraum welt zu entwickeln haben wir sechs jahre lang mit parabelflügen und in speziellen fallschirm und thermischen
vakuumkammern getestet so der projektleiter bei airbus ingo ritter der bus ist einer der
projektbeteiligten und bei dem verfahren mit dem netz wird es nicht bleiben in den kommenden
monaten soll eine hauptschule zum einsamen getestet werden und ein optisches
navigationssystem um die trümmer zu orten doch ob die technik dann im großen rahmen eingesetzt werden das ist noch sehr fraglich bisher gibt es nämlich
keinerlei vereinbarung zum aufnehmen von
weltraumschrott niemand fühlt sich verantwortlich und ein problem ist noch vollkommen ungeklärt
was machen wir mit alten großen schrott satelliten die steuerungs los durch das all fliegen der 8,2 tonnen schweren satelliten corot
envisat ist so ein kandidat seit april 2012
fliegt er vollkommen unkontrolliert im erdorbit ihn einzufangen und zu zerstören dürfte zig millionen kosten geld das
niemand ausgeben will wenn dieses problem aber nicht gelöst wird dann haben wir ein viel größeres problem beim kessel syndrom wird dann nämlich so ziemlich
alles im airport zerstört satelliten für gps telefonie internet wettervorhersagen und so weiter und so fort dazu noch die iss die
internationale raumstation und raumfahrt ist dann gar nicht mehr möglich ein gürtel von schrottteilen würde die erde um schließen wir würden um jahrzehnte zurückgeworfen
werden es wäre eine riesige katastrophe für die gesamte menschheit was denkt ihr über den weltraumschrott was muss getan werden
schreibt es in die kommentare
sobald wir weitere fortschritte erzielt werden da gibt es ja natürlich ein neues video wenn er das nicht verpassen und wenn ihr immer
garantiert über aktuelle videos informiert werden wollt dann
endet mich bei whatsapp nur dann bekommt ihr das aktuelle video deutlich vor allen anderen formiert persönlicher handy einfach hier draufklicken
und da drunter geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken live überwachung durch satelliten tausende neue mini satelliten im orbit bis dann
bleibt dran